الجيش السوداني ويقول بانه سيطر على احد
مقرات
قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم طبعا نرى في
هذه الصور مركبات محترقه مركبات عسكريه
محترقه
من الواضح بانه هذا المقر كما قصفه بشكل
كبير حتى تم السيطره عليه من قبل افراد
الجيش السوداني بحسب روايه الجيش وهذه
الصور والفيديوهات التي نراها الان
الله اكبر
شارع الغابه
الحمد لله تدمرت
وغطلاهم جوه كثيرين الزول يخشى او يخجلين
[تصفيق]
الوطن الوطن الوطن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
اليوم
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات